let me explain to these guys what's
going on rotten they might not have an
idea
all right Baba Booey is playing through
I'm sure they don't yes Rondo and
Richard bell Zoey I want to thank you
first of all Robin is going to be
appearing on Jeopardy I believe she has
an excellent chance of winning
especially celebrity jeopardy is always
they give you stupid questions so she's
gonna blow these guys away my friend
cheats one yes
so what we're doing is a warm-up session
right so that she is comfortable when
she gets there now you two guys are like
sparring partners for Robin all right
all right we want you to play your best
come here Robin no we want you to play
your best we want you to take this in a
serious manner right she's gonna be
kidding around Belzer nobody's
interested we'd like to do you know do
the numbers like those we need somebody
to actually pull the the numbers he
could be the card girl if he wants let's
bring in Chris Chris do you want to do
you want to turn the in other words when
I call a category would you like to turn
the card you want to do it okay good all
right good guys good lawyer great lawyer
and that old Jay case was a farce that's
all I'm gonna say about it I'm not gonna
get into it cuz we're here to help Robin
played us right all right okay here we
go I'm always a good attorney I don't
think he did a bad job on the case I
think he did a good job I got off but
okay
all right here we go all right we're
gonna play the game you know and by the
way let me remind everyone answer in
question form do you know that although
I never watch the show all right let me
give you the category please call me
everyone including Chris call me Alex
yeah no Alex because Robin has to get in
shape okay Chris vana if you want to
call Chris vana do that on vacation
categories are the following sports
definite and the right through sports
and specifically Robin because I hate
them that's right so if I plot it
against you I'm sorry but I've filled in
your training you should even get it
subjects that you're not particularly
good at sports definitions artists
actors and roles world geography and
Anatomy these are the categories that's
right and I'm gonna allow Robin tonight
first because she's the one going on
real jeopardy okay anatomy thank you and
thank you for calling me Alex here we go
Anatomy for 100 everyone pay attention
please remember to buzz in there'll be a
farting sound effect and come in part of
your body that has a root a crown and a
float cavity Robin Quivers that would
what is a tooth what is it tooth is 400
putting the Waldo in Belgium go ahead
Robin pick again Anatomy
one book describes it as a crumpled gray
jelly divided into two halves like a
walnut that was a Richard Richard
Richard Belzer it's called the brain but
that is wrong what
Geraldo Robin one book describes it as a
crumpled gray jelly divided into two
halves like a walnut rolled oh no I
don't know it's not a brain sounds like
a but that is incorrect
scrotum okay Robin yes the answer is
what is the brain
what is the brain what is the brain you
gotta allow me that I thought they gave
you one Chris could you be my attorney
for a second you want to play or you
want to I have to learn Anatomy for 300
Alex pale
there's too many bodily fluids on the
show yeah excuse me pale watery fluid
that bathes and feeds body tissues and
is cleaned and filtered by nodes Robin
that would be what is a lymph that is
correct for 300 right steel and you
almost had brain if you'd answered
properly I had a brain anatomy for 400
Alex sitting atop the kidneys are these
glands which supply the hormones that
kick in when you fight Robin what are
the adrenals good I like what I'm saying
[Music]
name of the twenty two twenty three foot
long tube comprised of the duodenum
Richard Richard got in first Richard
what are the intestines what is the
small intestine that is correct accident
Robin
sit down come on Geraldo embarrassingly
not even in devoured Robin it's your
turn let's go to definitions 400 good
and thank you for calling me alex is
very good to a little girl it's a hat to
an Indian a war headdress to a Londoner
the hood of a car Robin what is a bonnet
that is correct your honor man nice that
you got nurses wear bonnets Robin go
ahead let's go with definitions for 200
Alex it's the deliberate destruction of
hair roots using electric current Robin
what is electrolysis that is correct
Robin I have a full head of hair I
wouldn't know that peon ism is a fancy
word for this P an ism is a fancy word
for this Richard Belzer what is a piano
repairman what is piano playing or
technique well I'm sorry that is wrong -
300 rather surprisingly quite for a man
who supposedly has a law degree hey you
were a wer isn't a ram it's one of these
in the shape of the bottom what is a
lamb what it no that is wrong what is a
Vaz that's correct what is a picture or
jug that's correct
it's acceptable as well hey you were
Richard goes are still on the minus side
at minus 600 Harada minus six hundred
and sixteen hundred plus four Robyn
go ahead Robin my god excuse me actors
and role
alright actors and roles something you
guys should all be familiar with being
in the field of show business
except for you or although Leonard
Rosenberg ouch changed his name to this
before he played Felix Unger Robin
Quivers that would be Tony Oh what who
is Tony Randall man check with
Christopher Darden oh look at me this
was Steve McQueen's profession in both
his first TV series and his last film
Belgian what is a bounty hunt that is
correct for 200 Richard Belzer chooses
the category let's let's stay with the
with the show business premise here
actors and roles for 300 in the 1960s TV
series combat Vic Morrow and Rick Jason
were soldiers in this war that is
correct and that's 300 rather you can
world geography for 500 right things are
heating up now listen carefully for 500
all right
Tenerife te n e RI Fe Corrado where is
Spain
Oh what is Spain I'm sure what is the
Balearic Islands I'm sorry that is wrong
Tenerife is the largest of this Spanish
island group off the northwest coast of
Africa while though you cannot buzz in
you gotta come on okay what is the
Canaries that is wrong
all right what is wrong I'm gonna stop
this because Geraldo gave the right
answer two Canaries I'm not gonna deduct
points for Beltre because he said it
wrong yeah he can't buzzing twice you
cannot you cannot buzzing twice you
already gave the wrong we're gonna give
it to yelling because two of the three
Canadian provinces with two-word name's
Richard Belzer British Columbia remember
to answer your question for him Oh what
is British Columbia and what is Prince
George I'm sorry that is wrong
what is Nova Scotia oh and you have to
be too oh and what is British Columbia
that is correct okay here we go
Waldo coming on strong yeah Robin being
gracious and giving him Yeah right a
strip of land on the Mediterranean is
named for this city where Samson brought
down the house Geraldo what is Gaza that
is correct for 300,000 let me remind you
the score now is Robin 1700 or although
900 richer buzzer - 800 not too bright
all right go ahead geography in 1975
this Vietnamese city was renamed to
honor the late President of North
Vietnam Ho Chi Minh my god that is
correct for 200
sweeping sweeping this oud buzzing
quicken oh it's true silly pants go
ahead and choose all right christopher
darden doing an excellent job
if only oj was on trial and you were
doing this good ago here we go
I still say you did a great job in that
trial I don't care what anyone's name
I'm looking for work and all right this
isn't Pedro good though in May of 1988
this mountain became the highest spot on
earth from which a live TV broadcast
originated witness misery I was gonna
say mount st. Helens but that is wrong
that is wrong still that is correct for
a hundred you were doing you're on a
roll you're a 1200 Robin at 1700 in the
lead am richard belzer - don't keep
mentioning definitions definitions we've
500 we have one left in that category
here we go don't use your curry comb to
make curry powder you're supposed to do
this with it Robin what is comb your
hair I'm sorry that is wrong
Richard Belzer what is what is teaser
here I'm sorry that is wrong
[Music]
I have no clue alright it is what is
groom your horse that's minus 500 for
Robin Robins at 1200 or roldos at 1200
we have a tie up there and Richard
Belzer at - 1400 I was gave me money to
throw this I all right let's go back to
roldos turn artists for five ones
artists for 500 Wow Geraldo just going
for yeah played like a real maniac this
painter this painter of American
primitives Illustrated twas the night
before Christmas at age 100 Richard
Belzer who is that is correct with bells
you're almost you're only at minus 900 I
don't don't
continually ridicule me I'll walk gotta
go he was the most famous artist born on
the island of Crete Richard Belzer good
to buzz in when you don't even have a
clue no I well you got an answer or I'm
gonna have to disqualify you
I'm so sorry Geraldo or Robin he was the
most famous artist born on the island of
Crete man I'm so sorry
who was el Greco but he still had the
last right answer oh I see I will
continue with the artists once a sailor
and Paris stockbroker
he painted some of the finest works in
Tahiti oh that is wrong I'm sorry that
is correct
300
Ronna no cursing we have a good match on
our hands 904 Geraldo Robin in the lead
with 1200 - 900 for Richard Belzer he's
coming on strong go ahead Belzer let's
stay with artists came with a buzzer
gets to zero all right for 200 Picasso
was born in this country in 1881 but
spent most of his life in France Robin
that is correct all right for $400
actors and roles Robert De Niro fans got
a bang out of this 1973 film in which he
played a dying baseball player Richard
Belzer what is bang the drum slow that
is correct four hundred four hundred
bells are you - lets stay let's do the
five hundred on the actors in order she
she was Theo's math teacher on The Cosby
Show and the Spider Woman and kiss of
the Spider Woman that is correct for
five hundred I mean ice Robin Troy's
[Applause]
the only 100 yes that is correct that is
the only category left except for artist
set a hundred I would believe yes is
that true yes in the last 35 years this
team has had only two managers Walter
Alston and Tommy Lasorda hirama who are
the dodge that is correct for 100
Geraldo you see off sports for 500 okay
the salt the salt palace is home to this
NBA team in second place at 1500 Robert
in first place in 1900 Richard Belzer we
won't matter 300 sports okay
first American to win an Olympic gold
medal for individual performances in
women's gymnastics Robin who is Mary Lou
Retton that is correct for $300 Robin
you choose you have to okay this Italian
genius has been called the greatest
artist in the 1400s Robin who is I'm
sorry that's incorrect a Belzer
who is Leonardo DaVinci that is correct
all right that's minus 100 for Robin
plus 100 for Belzer and we have one left
I'll read it to you in sports for 200
here we go okay Alex and thank you
in July 1889 he won the last
professional bare-knuckle fight in the
US Richard Belzer
who is John L Sullivan that is correct
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Robin is in the lead at 2100 morado at
1500 I'm going to tell you our Final
Jeopardy Jeopardy category unfortunately
only Jurado and Robin can play in fact
Chris Darden scored more points than
Belgium he would be away Robin is at
presently a $2,100 Geraldo is at $1500
Bell's unfortunately Europe minus 200
you can't play Christie where to Sir
you are the letter turner so we can't
have you do that here's our final
Jeopardy category is birds pick birds
now Geraldo you have written down of
course how much you're gonna wager don't
tell us what it is Robin you have done
the same I am now going to give you the
question remember to answer answer form
an answer in answer they can bet the
full amount already from zero to the
full amount that they this could be a
it's gonna be interesting it's gonna be
a good still being upset the final
categories birds hide how much you
wagered please all right like a pelican
a frigate f RI Ga te a frigate bird has
one of these but only uses it to attract
mates by inflating it like a padam Paz
in just write your answer down question
form in question form like a pelican a
frigate bird has one of these but only
uses it to attract mates by inflating it
just like a pelican let's see what the
answer is
Belzer I ask you I'm just saying
fighting it I I beg of you
I beg of you I also have to bring up
your wife again press the same of you
please no cheating
I'll bring up the illegitimate children
all right now please okay I see the Pens
are down
the category is birds let's go - don't
give us your answer yet Geraldo since
you're you have 1500 like a pelican a
frigate bird has one of these but only
uses it to attract mates by inflating it
what did your answer first what is a
gullet alright that is wrong how much
did you wager 1,700 I wanted to if I
lost they weren't the tie bill but you
came alright let's see let's see Robin
what is your answer I didn't know the
answer either I almost wrote garlic -
and I knew that was wrong so I said what
is that pouch under that is correct that
is correct
pouch what did you wager that is correct
and what is the your final score is 2600
nicely done you've whipped these guys
pouch is the correct answer what is a
pouch and there it is game
she was a nurse yet all the Anatomy
questions your tip for your into an
hints although graciously kissing robin
Belzer don't make any illegitimate
children with Robin please Corrado
he's practically screwing her right
[Music]